el del radio canadá internacional este
reencuentro semanal que les proponemos a
partir de cada vez más vías de
comunicación ya que estamos no solamente
transmitiendo como hacemos habitualmente
nuestra emisión los días domingos a
partir de nuestro sitio internet www rc
y net punto sea que buena edición sino
que además sumamos el canal de facebook
live que ustedes ya lo conocen lo
venimos experimentando hace un poco más
de un año un año y medio dos tal vez los
datos no son muy precisos en ese sentido
y si no tenemos una fecha así como para
festejar el aniversario de nuestro
facebook
y acabamos de sumar como ustedes ya
saben también nuestro canal a partir de
youtube que nos pueden seguir allí saben
que transmitimos también en directo en
nuestro sitio internet los viernes a
esta hora qué vas a hacer uno cual ahora
es porque la hora aquí en canadá cambio
pero en el inicio sur no ha cambiado por
ejemplo eso quiere decir que nuestro
público nos está escuchando en este
momento
distinto preguntarles a qué hora nos
están escuchando ya serían las 11
saludamos a todos ustedes los saludamos
a quienes nos siguen a través del
facebook live y le damos una vez más la
bienvenida estamos hoy aquí en el
estudio en un equipo poco habitual para
esta emisión tiene como estas
[Música]
un saludo un saludo a los amigos que nos
escuchan en chubut
boots y seguramente por allá habrá algún
algún amigo de radio canadá
internacional en la patagonia en la
patagonia y donde martín fierro así a
esas preciadas justamente rufo valencia
que está pidiendo a gritos una
parrillada y en cualquier momento lo
vamos a satisfacer sí y también están
leonardo gimeno que tal como los días
buenos días a todos y buenos días a la
gente
por las redes sociales tardes sí sí
bueno en general
bueno mi nombre es luis laborda una vez
más aquí con todos ustedes y iniciando
entonces este reencuentro semanal que
ustedes saben que es más coincidencia y
vaya dato el que corresponde al último
fin de semana del invierno lo logramos
lo logramos hemos sobrevivido bueno sí
igual es una misma época no termina el
invierno
especialmente si en el calendario pero
van a la calle por favor quiere crear un
facebook la semana próxima nos
programamos programamos y hago yo
una emisión desde la calle para
mostrarles lo que es oficialmente el
martes oficialmente el martes comienza
la primavera en el hemisferio norte así
que todos nosotros deberíamos estar en
todos es un poco más contento de saber
que al menos formalmente el invierno
comienza a quedarte atrás y igual hay
una onda 10 por suerte como cambio la
ahora tenemos más horas de sol y eso sí
se refleja tengo un dato maravilloso hoy
es el primer día del año del año
wind el año de este año 2018 que el sol
se va a dormir después de las 7 de la
noche aquí en mante nación le dio
permiso pues es no sé pero me parece
maravilloso porque recuerdan en
noviembre se iba a las 4 de larvas sino
ya estamos a las siete y pico todavía
tenemos un poco de sol pero el sol como
tal
7 hoy a partir de hoy se va
que era del sol
hay un sol enorme
nosotros nos decían que era la bandera
de guerra una época el sol el sol en la
bandera de japón
son la bandera del sol de cielo rojo ahí
que llama mucho la atención ser
condición de decisiones y está también
en la frente de un montón de indios
es casada exacto tiene que ver con la
situación marital me encanta me encanta
como saltamos del sol y de la bandera
la cuestión es que formalmente la
primavera comienza el martes y yo creo
que mereceríamos festejarla porque
después de invierno que hemos pasado que
estamos pasando por bien sentido
leonardo tiene razón todavía no ha
terminado y parece ser que se va a
extender un poquito más de lo que
debería ha sido un invierno problemático
cansador
con mucha verdad pensando que dices
quizá habría que cambiar no me el
programa habría que ponerle en lugar de
castor mensajero a la ardilla boreal
porque vamos de rama en rama
congelada imposible bueno estimados
colegas y amigos cuáles son los temas
que les han llamado la atención en los
últimos días fuera de lo que es la
actualidad candente como se dice
pues yo estuve un poco consternada esta
semana y si tiene que ver con la
actualidad por el asesinato de mari el
franco la concejala brasileña que fue
asesinada en plena calle hace un par de
días el miércoles me parece fue el
miércoles sí y terminando una sesión de
discusión con mujeres negras del sur de
su zona de vías mostró se había mostrado
mariel franco muy combativa con respecto
a la presencia policial y militar en las
favelas en río y reforzado en los
últimos meses por decisión del propio
presidente y tener exactamente entonces
mariela villamaría el franco había
presentado bastante oposición a esta
presencia militar y policial y ahora
resulta que fue asesinada entonces me
consternó bastante ese fue el tema que
me preocupó esta semana y al menos la
ciudad de río de janeiro sigue
militarizada
con el supuesto objetivo o el objetivo
oficial en todo caso de combatir la ola
de crímenes que hay en las favelas de
río de janeiro y de otras ciudades de
brasil
y sobre todo el narcotráfico aunque no
no han faltado casos de habitantes de
esos barrios carenciados que han dicho
que con la presencia militar se sienten
más inseguros aún y un caso como el que
vamos a acaba de citar tal vez podría
llegar a darles la razón exactamente y
justo un día antes antes de haber sido
asesinada mari él había enviado un
twitter un tweet a su cuenta en el que
decía otro asesinato de un joven de un
joven que se agrega a la cuenta del
primer ministro
matheus me lo estaba saliendo de la
iglesia refiriéndose al joven cuántas
personas tendrán que morir para que
termine esta guerra fue lo que marc y el
franco había publicado en su cuenta de
twitter el día anterior a haber sido
asesinado y eso tan cerca al 8 de marzo
lo cual la prueba justamente de que el
camino para
las mujeres tengan su justo lugar si se
puede hacer una formación que suena muy
general pero eso es pues larguísimo es
durísimo es ahora y está activista que
además concejala había crecido en las
favelas de río era será su casa conocía
a su terreno conocía a su gente y la
defendía y bueno todos lo conocemos cuán
inestable puede llegar a ser el ambiente
político y social en los diversos países
que componen américa latina pero qué
momento lo que está viviendo brasil en
con una presidenta que fue desalojada
por decisión del parlamento pero que uno
sabe que hubo negociaciones no del todo
claras con un presidente que se mantiene
en el poder a pesar de estar cada día
más discutido con una violencia que
muchos refieren como si fuera nueva pero
que en realidad no es tan nueva aunque
ha resurgido en los últimos tiempos de
mercado en un proceso contra un ex
presidente que durante su mandato fue la
mejor época de brasil por lo menos en
los últimos 50 años y es la intenta
impedir que
a ser candidato en las próximas
elecciones
esa es la el rostro del neoliberalismo y
justamente algo que me que también
podemos traer a colación es justamente
el cambio en la dirección de la cia
ahora es una torturador a quien está a
cargo de la cia y en entrevista previa
un ex director de la cia decía que esta
nación en américa latina y él decía
justamente como había comentado bueno
este está estamos haciendo cosas así que
pues no se puede separar esto de lo que
pasó en el golpe de estado en brasil a
lo que a todas aquellas acciones
justamente contra gobiernos que tratan
de distribuir mejor la torta no sé a mí
me llama la atención en realidad
cambiando de tema esta semana dos cosas
una a la desaparición de un niño aquí en
montreal que no se sabe nada eso es lo
que me llama más la atención
estando tan comunicados están conectados
tan tan todo que no se sepa
absolutamente nada eso realmente me da
escalofríos y otra cosa es la muerte del
espía
en inglaterra antes de pasar ese te
mataremos que en el caso del chico al
cual referías es un niño de diez diez
años que desapareció en un trayecto
relativamente corto entre su casa y la
casa de una mujer que exactamente iba a
visitar luego había entendido que nunca
había llegado a esa casa pero la vamos
con paloma hoy me decía que la última
información indica que llegó a la casa
del amigo y que como el pequeño al cual
iba a visitar no estaba presente
supuestamente se volvía a su casa pero
nunca más volvió a aparecer y hay
imágenes que lo muestran en el trayecto
y comentábamos palomas que hay algunas
imágenes que parecerían mostrarlo con un
cierto nerviosismo no comentó en
realidad son imágenes de cámaras de la
ciudad que se lo ve caminando en la
dirección contraria a la casa de su
amigo digamos volviendo hacia su casa
pero él caminaba y luego volteaba y se
volvía y volvía a tomar camino
bolt volteo en dos o tres ocasiones
cuando uno siente que viene alguien
siguiendo entonces volteo en varias
ocasiones y esa es la imagen que me
quedó marcada de ver al niño que está
caminando en dirección desde su casa y
que tiene como una preocupación detrás
de él y si bien la preocupación crece
porque se van muchas horas sin rastro
sobre el pequeño esperemos que la
situación no derive en su peor en lo que
me llama la atención es justamente el
caso de flipper
los nombres de felipe es un robot que no
es un robot que puede freír 2000
hamburguesas por hora
temor por el tema de la obesidad
entonces lo que pasa es que este robot
lo fue puesto a funcionar en una cadena
de hamburguesas en eeuu
pues resulta que tuvieron que retirar no
solamente un día apenas pasado un día
porque lo sacaron de servicio porque no
interactuaba adecuadamente con sus
colegas humanos lo que pasa es que
seguramente lo que pasaba es que
mientras el flipper hacía tres o cuatro
o cinco hamburguesas la otra persona
todavía estaba poniendo la cebolla el
tomate no lo sé pero cubierto es que lo
he visto a flipper varios flippers en
distintos lugares para directamente
dejar sin trabajo toda esa gente y hacer
productiva la cadena exa tilly los y lo
que es grave es que bueno es que estamos
siendo un modelo de producción en que es
el ser humano que tiene que adecuarse a
la máquina y es una carrera al infinito
ese sinclar ese es ese es el suicidio
del colectivo de edu desde el del
mercado laboral humano ahora qué pasaría
si con jugásemos este tal flipper este
robot al cual vuestra referir que tiene
estas aptitudes tan increíbles para
cocinar hamburguesas con esa parrillada
que estás deseando sean cesiones
tiene que ser hecha por humanos porque
tiene que ver un poco de vino
conversación probar un poco la carne
como está hablar de los méritos de la de
la difunta vaca
además querías hacer también referencia
a este espía en verdad a mí lo que me
llama la atención es que ni siquiera sé
en profundidad es en realidad casi nada
del caso pero lo que me llama la
atención es que ese tipo de cosas las
muertes de espías y eso nosotros lo
pedimos en las películas en fin y ahora
está saliendo a la luz y es descarado o
sea es realmente increíble que esto siga
pasando en el siglo 21
parece estuviéramos en el siglo 19
y en todos lados en todas las sociedades
pasa de esta nueva y de alguien que no
le gusta algo más listo se lo bajas por
en este caso lo han entrenado y todavía
es bastante dudoso lo que ha ocurrido de
hecho esta mañana una noticia con
declaraciones del líder de la oposición
británica georgie corbin que pide
mesura en las declaraciones y sobre todo
en las represalias que el gobierno
británico y otros gobiernos quieren
tomar en contra de rusia porque él dice
hasta ahora no hay pruebas de lo que ha
sucedido no está demostrado
fehacientemente qué es lo que ocurrió y
tampoco descarto jamie corbin alguna
teoría que no es tan descabellada
tampoco que es el hecho de que en lugar
de ser directamente el gobierno ruso que
puede estar implicado en esta situación
puede hacer bien la mafia rusa ya que la
cual inglaterra está llena por los
cuatro costados y otro aspecto de esta
de esta información es justamente y
quizá el que yo veo mucho mucho para
quien creo que hay un poco de parecido
entre / lissette mail la primera
ministra británica r mach3 m 13m y mark
tacher porque mark tacher si va al tacho
en las elecciones hasta que apareció el
conflicto a las malvinas quien le llevó
la a la reelección un instrumento
inglaterra se está yendo al tacho en
historia de nación del brics y es un
fracaso total es un desastre es un
gobierno ella fue por lana y salió
trasquilado con de mónaco una
anticipada en que se suponía que iban a
ganar un mayor mandato para negociar con
más fuerza el break pero sucedió
justamente lo contrario y hay ese
problema grave en en inglaterra que va
le va a costar miles y miles de millones
de libras el poder es ese divorcio que
en el fondo y una de las razones de ese
divorcio es justamente también tocó su
papel jugó su papel el racismo si en esa
sociedad sí claro y en este caso tres a
menos cuenta con un general borracho que
le salve de las papas como ocurrió con
margaret thatcher y él tiene en su
momento aunque volviendo ayer mis colmen
del recuerdo donde dice que debe tener
mesura en lo que lo que declara y en las
vidas que adopta porque no sea que le
vaya a ocurrir lo mismo que ocurrió con
las famosas armas de destrucción masiva
que se usó como argumento en la época
del presidente estadounidense george
bush para invadir irán y manera de irak
perdón y más tarde esas armas nunca
aparecieron que no use ahora el
argumento de la rusia envenenando gente
para distraer
atención de la situación política
vigente en este momento en gran bretaña
y que luego aparezca como que rusia no
ha tenido nada que ver en ese tema y hay
algo que recuerdo que las declaraciones
de mis relaciones exteriores ruso lávrov
que decía lo que está pasando lo que
inglaterra no está haciendo es es seguir
las normas en este tipo de casos hay
instrucciones internacionales que son
veedores imparciales supuestamente que
pueden que hay un proceso que seguir en
este tipo de casos que inglaterra se
pasa por encima entonces ahí hay mucho
de geopolítica mucho de intereses y de
alguna forma hemos vuelto a una pregunta
que hacía bien si estados si eeuu ganó
la guerra fría porque hay este
enfrentamiento nuevamente porque alguien
quiere recordar porque hay necesidad de
una nueva guerra fría para tapar otras
cosas la teoría del complot es
fantástica
bueno aquí tengo un mensaje de nelson
contra el rincón que si buenos días un
salud dictó corto desde barranquilla
colombia estoy en una capacitación los
escucharé el fin de semana bueno
y esta es una de las de las cosas que
nos ofrece la tecnología que este
programa va a estar en realidad está en
vivo ahora en youtube en facebook live y
en nuestro sitio y va a estar el vídeo
en tanto en facebook en youtube y en
nuestro sitio a partir de hoy hasta el
domingo así que en este caso nelson
podrá escuchar el programa cuando tenga
tiempo para hacerlo que es cuando tenga
tiempo en eso también nos podría contar
un poco de qué trata esa capacitación de
eso ahora caballeros y damas
algunas cosas son no te gusta una buena
cerveza fría en cualquier momento
cualquier hacia la marca tengo poca
experiencia en la cultura de la cerveza
que ahora se está poniendo muy de moda
el hecho estas cervezas con gustos estas
cervezas artesanales y especiales las
cervezas con gusto en alguien tiene otro
y escuché una cerveza con gusto alfajor
me parece me parece extraordinario yo
tengo hace un año más o menos una caja
de cervezas saborizadas que no logró
terminar
si te interesa yo no lo recomiendo
saben que quien que ve que en canadá en
general se producen muchísimas cervezas
artesanales se consumen también pero se
producen muchas cervezas artesanales con
sabores citó y son ricas pues saben
ustedes que no somos los únicos que
piensan en la cerveza de vez en cuando
en bélgica aparentemente él
público es amante de la cerveza blanca
no lo sé pero parece ser que al público
le gusta no solamente la cerveza sino el
recipiente en el cual esta cerveza se
sirve porque numerosos bares dedicados
al consumo de cerveza efectivamente no
nos pierden si nos roban el juego se
roba las vasos de cerveza en bélgica y
aquí hay el caso por ejemplo del
propietario de una cafetería que está en
la ciudad de brujas que ha decidido
invertir 4 mil euros en un sistema de
alarmas que se instalarán se integra
cada alarma en cada vaso en el cual se
sirve cerveza para evitar que la gente
se los siga robando porque porque ha
perdido en el plazo del último año 4000
de esos vasos ha tenido que volver a
comprar cuatro mil vasos que ha perdido
yo tengo una explicación para eso
equipos o yo estuve en brujas y estuve
en méxico algunos días y me parecieron
lindos los
porque son como muy tradicionales te
imaginas un vaso de cerveza y ahí te lo
sirven en ese tipo de vasos de cerveza
entonces muchos turistas
me imagino que son los turistas
no me traje o no ahora que lo ve el que
lo piensa lo hubiera hecho y esta
cervecería no es el único caso hay otra
cervecería que ha encontrado otra
eventual solución que es el hecho de
pedirle a cada consumidor cuando pide
una copa un vaso de cerveza un zapato en
garantía
entonces cuando usted pide una cerveza
tiene que entregar en el mostrador un
zapato y que hacen los propietarios de
esta otra cervecería que está ubicada en
la ciudad de gante no sé cómo se
pronuncia exactamente
ponen este zapato en una canasta que
está
digamos unida con un sistema de poleas
en el techo entonces colocan el zapato
en esa canasta la elevan hasta el techo
la canasta y si usted quiere recuperar
sus zapatos antes de irse el bar tiene
que devolver el vaso
aunque lo que debería hacer es
simplemente venderles el vaso al negocio
si no va a ser vasos de cables claros
descartables o inclusive hay vasos hay
ahora hay lugares donde te sirve una
sopa en un pan y te comes la ropa y el
pan y está alimentando cubierta se los
puedes comer importante ahí es el orden
ustedes son de llevarse cosas de
recuerdos de los lugares que visitan
confías en confiesen
yo no podría decir porque estamos al
aire
significa un compromiso legal una
persona entregada
pero recuerda la época en la que la
gente se roba o se llevaba los ceniceros
de algún bar los posavasos pero eso es
me parece que estaban dispuestos para
que la gente se los llevara porque se
llevaban los vasos y dejaban posavasos
ya nuestros posavasos caminando y nadie
decía nada o sea creo que esta colección
cuando era niña me llevaba las llaves de
los hoteles que visitábamos las llaves
de los cuartos de los hoteles tenía una
colección muy un montón de puertas de un
hotel en londres al que después volví
muchas veces que me regaló las llaves de
la habitación la miramos la segunda vez
que fui me regaló la llave de esa
habitación la llave que me regaló fue la
tarjeta electrónica con la que se abre
la puerta que después darle programa con
nuestra tarjeta nosotros pero me pareció
un gesto bonito
que me conmovió los amigos y si cometen
este tipo de actos de piratería que se
animen a confesar y no tienen que dar
detalles no además un poco de
información solamente sus nombres número
de documentos de elección y una
declaración del valor del objeto que sea
una de esas frazadas del avión sino
también yo también yo me sentí muy
culpable y en el último viaje no no lo
voy a hacer y una persona bajó con dos
frazadas en la mano no sé si porque le
dio vergüenza decirle que mandan con
anteojitos para que no ver la luz de más
cosas tomando en cuenta la tendencia que
está en vigor en este momento y de hace
ya algún tiempo yo creo que la aerolínea
dentro de poco que van a vender hasta el
asiento para semana
físico
vas a pagar tu pasaje y si te crees en
tal que hay que comprar asiento porque
si siguen así no te van a dar pero ni
las gracias y un saludo
bueno muy bien esta ha sido la primera
parte de esta emisión ya volvemos en
unos segundos solamente
[Música]
más
bueno muy bien tenemos entonces algunos
mensajes de nuestros oyentes que se nos
van acumulando cada vez más con un
mensaje que dice canadá y su plan de
inmigración 2018
marisé hernández santana mandó mensaje
dice hola me llamo mar y ser no de
santana soy ingeniera química con dos
años de graduada y de experiencia
laboral en una industria farmacéutica
quiero saber qué proyectos pueden
solicitar para vivir en canadá en una
parte de habla inglesa muchas gracias
espero su respuesta pronto saludos y le
decimos a mari sé que la opción
animalidad y quizás con la posibilidad
de mayor resultado es entrar al sitio de
inmigración canadá y registrarse y ver
cuáles son las posibilidades dependiendo
del lugar que haya texto folk sobre el
mismo tema en este nos escribe indicando
que estoy totalmente de acuerdo con el
plan de migración 2018 en que amplíen
las formas de apadrinar a hermanos
también y que sean más flexibles en el
aspecto laboral esto ayudaría en gran
manera a canadá y también a las personas
que vivimos aquí y nos gustaría tener a
nuestro familia
con nosotros algo más que quiero
decirles es que las personas que
comentan que desean venir a vivir a
canadá toda la información la encuentran
en el sitio web de migración del
gobierno que nada que nada punto sea
servicios inmigración ciudadanía
etcétera soy del ecuador y vine a este
hermoso país de oportunidades en la
categoría de trabajador calificado lo
que hay que tener es paciencia diciendo
bien las cosas al final se obtiene la
residencia permanente dios les bendiga
dice adriana muy bien paloma tengo aquí
un mensaje que llega desde españa es de
sandra camps españa también se llama se
se nombra así es un un comentario sobre
el reportaje la prostitución tiene cara
juvenil en la web es un reportaje que
había hecho leonor a chapman en el año
2016 pero que sigue generando
comentarios
sandra dice en españa tenemos más
control sobre estos servicios sexuales
bajo mi punto de vista habría que
legalizar los como en otros países yo
estoy a favor de que algunas chicas si
deciden vender su cuerpo lo hagan pero
de forma legal entonces un comentario
sandra camps al reportaje de leonora la
prostitución tiene cara juvenil en la
web y yo tengo un mensaje breve que nos
envía will back que firma como wilb aquí
sobre los empleos más buscados por las
empresas canadienses que nos dice hola
mi nombre es huelva quiero trabajar en
canadá
soy ferretero plomero contable mercadeo
etcétera es decir se dedica a varios
rubros entonces ellos no podría darles
ningún tipo de certeza le puedo asegurar
que como ferretero y como plomero va a
tener mucho éxito a tener bastante éxito
aquí así que si se siente alentado a
buscar suerte aquí en canadá ingrese
como acaba de decir recién llenarlo a la
página de el servicio de inmigración de
inmigración canadiense y ahí va a tener
va a encontrar toda la información
respectiva algún otro mensaje si yo
tengo dos cortos uno dice sobre el tema
más vegetarianos y veganos entre los
jóvenes canadienses persie dice cura
eficaz para la diabetes en realidad yo
no me aventuraría sino los médicos la
diabetes recomendarían ser veganos a
todo el que tenga diabetes
sería así si una cura efectiva así que
ese es el comentario de percy y otro
mensaje que dice facebook toma cartas en
el asunto del porno de la venganza dice
esas cosas se pueden denunciar e incluso
llegar a poder ganar fácilmente con
compañías así dice sandra aunque con
facebook es más difícil que con google
por lo que he visto ya que tienen más
derechos que están pero no nos fijamos
cuando creamos la cuenta cuando
participamos perfecto sobre el tema
justamente efe
toma cartas en asunto del porno de la
venganza creo que es caro lópez quien
dice que aunque facebook luche contra
este problema la verdad es que lo veo
muy difícil ya que la extorsión por
internet y ese tipo de cosas siempre va
a estar ahí la solución dice nuestro
oyente es dejar de grabar nos teniendo
sexo o mostrar fotos explícitas de
nosotros por internet es una opción
mucho más fácil sí
y un comentario muy cortito pero que le
parece interesante y preocupante un
reportaje que hizo leonor a chapman
sobre la contaminación atmosférica que
causa 7 mil 700 muertes prematuras en
canadá cada año luz aleida ortiz dice
cordial saludo muy interesante y
preocupante el informe y claro pues
nunca pensamos que causa tantas muertes
prematuras a la contaminación por año
bueno yo tengo que un mensaje sobre la
falta de mano de obra en las plantas es
que era el atlántico canadiense que nos
mal nos manda perdón laura chang y dice
buenas noches soy del estado de campeche
mi hija tiene 13 años con una escoliosis
de 68 grados o sea el título de este
mensaje está mal puesto el especialista
nos indicó cirugía lo más pronto y yo
quisiera saber o tener información al
respecto me gustaría saber cuánto sale
la cirugía y material ya que no contamos
con muchos recursos si me pueden
orientar muchísimas gracias bueno se
refiere a un tema que hemos publicado
dentro del nuevo de los diversos temas
médicos que tratamos frecuentemente aquí
entra yo de canadá
tenemos información en este momento de
cuánto puede salir ese tipo de cirugías
pero les recomendamos que asista al
médico cuando pueda tener la información
precisa consultando nuestro sitio de
internet donde encontrará el material
respectivo buenos días mi nombre es
claudia saldivia director musical del
conjunto proyecto altiplano y los invito
a escuchar canadá en las américas café
de radio canadá internacional bueno muy
bien y antes de seguir con la lectura de
mensajes de nuestros oyentes qué tal si
les presentamos a ellos los materiales
con los que estuvimos trabajando esta
semana quien quiere comenzar a presentar
su material privilegia a álvaro en
realidad el material que yo les propongo
tiene que ver con esta luz que se apagó
pero que nos deja importantes aportes
tanto al ser humano común como la
ciencia en general estamos hablando de
stephen hawking que falleció a los 76
años después de haber vivido toda su
vida con una con una enfermedad grave
que lo postró en una silla y que lo
obligaba a
comunicarse con unos aparatos especiales
que bueno en realidad gracias a esos
aparatos pudo seguir trabajando esa
mente brillante y entregarnos teorías
con las cuales hoy se debate el futuro y
el futuro de la ciencia en el eje cuando
le fue diagnosticada esta enfermedad a
los 21 años los médicos le dieron dos o
tres años de sobrevida y vivió 55 años
eso es para darse por vencido es
realmente una un ejemplo a seguir y
bueno en realidad en el artículo que yo
les propongo lo que hago es mostraron
quizás las cuatro o cinco los cuatro o
cinco elementos con los cuales él
perdurará en esta historia que nosotros
estamos viviendo un stephen hawking que
es una de las mentes más brillantes que
dio el siglo 20 que revolucionó la
teoría sobre el universo en general y
quizás uno de los más populares después
de einstein para todo el mundo pregunta
quién es einstein bueno uno sabe y
hopkins hacking es exactamente lo mismo
digamos o sea son esas personas que y
bueno en particularmente en la que en el
caso de él es que logró algo que
no había logrado y que era vulgarizar la
ciencia escribió para que la gente común
entendiera si bien es bastante complejo
también en los textos de la gente común
pero él escribió para tratar de acercar
la física las matemáticas la cosmología
que era su su elemento principal para
que la gente lo entendiera mejor y eso
realmente es súper importante y fue
quien buscó dar una explicación más
detallada de lo que se llama la gran
explosión el famoso big bang' que
refieren muchos como el origen del
universo
y en gran parte se estudia sobre los
agujeros negros es sobre la energía y
tal de los agujeros negros y en una hace
un par de años dijo que en realidad
el comienzo de la existencia fue con el
big band y el final va a ser un agujero
negro pero decía que los agujeros negros
no eran tan negros que emitían luz
también en los descubrimientos de jaques
y que en realidad ese primero partía
desde su reflexión teórica y luego
probada y hay un montón de teorías de
hopkins que siguen siendo investigadas y
como por ejemplo el reactor este que hay
de ayones están tratando de probar cosas
que él él mismo aseguró a través de su
discurso teórico no hay una anécdota
conocida con su hija cuando era
pequeñita que le preguntó papá qué pasa
si me caigo en un agujero negro y le
dijo te conviertes en un fideo
y a ella me impactó esa explicación pero
digamos que eso se encadenó con algo que
después ella si la reconoció a su padre
que fue el hecho de que siempre tiene
una respuesta para todo cuando un niño
le hacía alguna pregunta y de ahí el
famoso libro de la teoría de fideos es
cuando algún niño le hace una pregunta
intentaba dar una explicación entendible
para el niño pero no lo dejaba sin
respuesta como ocurre frecuentemente
sobre todo cuando los chicos intentan
abordar con los adultos problemas o
cuestiones que son complicadas y
difíciles de explicar su ausencia éste
lo que traigo lo que propongo a nuestros
oyentes y es justamente que se adquiera
este reportaje sobre las declaraciones
del presidente estadounidense donald
trump el pasado miércoles en una cena
para recaudar fondos en un evento en
misurí él se jactó públicamente de
haberle literalmente mentido al primer
ministro canadiense jazz incluido en el
tema del déficit comercial entre eeuu y
canadá
lo concreto es que canadá según los
propios documentos firmados por de
bagram eeuu canadá es uno de los pocos
países con los cuales eeuu tiene un
superávit comercial de más o menos dos
mil millones de dólares aunque algunos
cálculos también elevan hasta ocho mil
millones de dólares es decir que en el
intercambio todos unidos resulta
beneficiar pero trump dice que le dice
que viene este hombre guapo etcétera y
me dice que que no tenemos que canadá no
tiene déficit con estados unidos y todo
cuenta insta el audio puede escuchar
diciendo elige genera usted y si tienen
un déficit nosotros sufrimos que
bogusevic esta hambre nos estamos
perdiendo a causa de ustedes básicamente
es el mensaje no
y admite que no sabía si eso era cierto
o no mandó a uno de sus como dicen en
méxico escuincles
uno de sus empleados a verificar si
efectivamente era cierto o no y lo
concreto es que efectivamente eeuu tiene
un superávit comercial con canadá
entonces lo que es lo que el propio ex
embajador canadiense estadounidense en
que nadal le mandó en twitter a cambio
de que no les mientan a los amigos no
puedes actuar de esa forma tan
irresponsable en una relación que como
dice el responsable de la de los
intercambios con eeuu del lado
canadiense él dice que diariamente hay
un intercambio comercial de 2 mil
millones de dólares y estamos justamente
en un momento en que se está discutiendo
el futuro del tratado de comercio
entonces hay un presidente que pues se
pone a discutir
al nombre de un país con canadá sobre la
cuestión comercial y el tío después se
inventa cosas nos dice la verdad y eso
según otros otros críticos señalan que
esto le quita credibilidad a donald
trump en momentos en que tenga que por
ejemplo tratar temas de suma gravedad a
nivel internacional en la medida en que
le quede todavía cierto todos iguales lo
que a mí más me impacta esta historia es
que es miente sin descaro tiene
acusaciones por abuso sexual y sigue
estando en la cabeza de uno de los
países más importantes del mundo eso lo
que yo no entiendo se está sabemos que
tiene tiene tendencia es a mentir tiene
tendencia a exagerar tiene tendencia a
decir cosas sin sentido
el otro día estábamos mirando en nuestra
sala de trabajo y decía algo como si
esto va a ir muy bien
o sea realmente tiene cero tacto desde
la diplomacia de la política y sin
embargo sigue ocupando ese lugar de
privilegio ahora lo interesante la
reacción de canadá porque hablan en la
prensa canadiense no hubo ni nota aún a
una mayor reacción de enojo por decir
así lo que decía por hanwerker que era
que fue consejero del primer ministro
brian long y decía que ante esta
realidad no vale la pena dejar sin mejor
no hacer nada porque la estrategia de
canadá ha sido actuar en función a los
datos al concreto a lo mensurable a lo
medible y que actúa de otra forma y va a
iba digamos a desviar o iba a distraer
digamos el enfoque canadiense que es no
solamente va a condonar chrome sino
también a hablar sobre todo con todas
las estructuras los elementos en altura
que pueden tomar decisiones como son
gobernadores de estados legisladores de
los estados que están detrás del apoyo a
las sanciones a los aranceles que por
ejemplo quiere imponer al acero y el
aluminio entonces
lo que estaba haciendo es manejar la
información y hacerla circular en los
niveles medios de decisión que al final
son los que van a decidir el día y
también que digamos respetan una
tradición canadiense y evitando en todo
caso que se dañe
la relación con un país que hoy por hoy
es gobernado por un presidente como
trump pero que no va a ser gobernado
eternamente por el mismo personaje
cuando esta persona se vaya dentro de
tres años o dentro de ocho años o siete
años si es que si llegara a ser reelecto
vendrá otro presidente y los países
seguirán existiendo y las relaciones
deberán seguir su curso también entonces
no se puede permitir que esto se dañe no
es cierto es el principal socio
comercial de canadá eeuu entonces
evidentemente no se pueden permitir un
rol que se rompa la relación entre
tienen que mantener el balance de alguna
manera y eso es lo que están hace sobre
todo porque ya ha habido un par de
pequeñas elecciones en las cuales han
triunfado candidatos o que no pertenecen
al no solamente al partido sino al
sector que responde directamente de otra
con lo cual no yo no creo que sea tan
alocado pensar en que no puedas
sobrevivir en que logre sobrevivir mejor
dicho una primera presidencia mucha
gente lucha como reelecto yo no estoy
tan seguro de que pueda triunfar en una
futura elección sino aquí decíamos que
iba a durar dos años aquí va a ser yo lo
que no creo es que lo destituyan no creo
que estados unidos esté preparado para
destituir un presidente para lo cual es
tu última para esta semana esta semana
estuve conversando por vídeo con una
chica su nombre es stern elsa ella tiene
un blog en el que da consejos sobre cómo
tratar el cabello crespo el cabello
rizado del ángulo de exactamente de las
mujeres negras y lo interesante de esta
conversación con ella fue que nos
explica las razones por las cuales ella
decidió armar este blog y no es por
razones de belleza sino por razones de
orgullo y por razones de herencia
ancestral ella que ella cuenta que a
través de la historia negra
las mujeres e incluso los hombres han
estado muy avergonzados del cabello
crespo a través de la historia porque
porque cuando los cuando los negros
vinieron de áfrica como esclavos los sus
amos entre comillas les prohibían para
tomar el tiempo necesario para tratar su
cabello que es especial y que es
diferente entonces decidieron cortarse
el cabello lo renegaron por mucho tiempo
entonces por eso es que vemos a tantas
mujeres y hombres negros que se alistan
el cabello y que utilizan productos
tóxicos muy importantes en el cabello
paralizarlos porque están avergonzados
de él de este cabello entonces ella
reivindica la llevar el cabello crespo
al natural y explica cómo se puede
utilizar y cómo puede uno sentirse
orgulloso de esta herencia y de esto que
es algo parte parte de su identidad
perfecto y yo muy brevemente bueno que
haya casi tiempo
invito les convidó con una entrevista un
diálogo que mantuve el lunes último con
xavier page que es el presidente de la
firma smart a lo que ellos diseñaron son
un tres o cuatro inventores de aquí de
la ciudad de montreal que diseñaron una
especie de sistema guía para las
bicicletas sabemos que la bicicleta es
un medio de transporte muy popular en
esta ciudad ahora que se acerca el buen
tiempo la gente comenzará a utilizarla
con mayor agilidad y no siempre resulta
fácil circular por montreal con
bicicletas sobre todo porque a veces hay
congestionamientos de tránsito etcétera
entonces esta especie de gps que es un
pequeño bar o luminoso tiene luces
verdes y rojas y nos indica para qué
lado doblar que debía seguir según la
información que le llega a este sistema
a través de un satélite y según siga
luces verde se puede hablar por ese lado
y para dónde es roja conviene evitar es
un funcionamiento muy simple que evita
de mantener el teléfono en la mano que
genera distracciones y posibilidades de
accidente que es lo que le pasó al
presidente de esta empresa
el sistema lamentablemente no tenemos
más tiempo
les agradecemos una vez más su presencia
aquí escuchando seguirnos cada semana en
canal en las américas café saludamos a
todos los que nos siguen a través de
facebook like de youtube y de nuestro
sitio en internet y nos despedimos hasta
la próxima con un tema musical que se
llama caminando hacia el sol
la primavera sigue bienvenido entonces
[Música]
no siempre resulta fácil circular por
montreal con bicicletas sobre todo
porque a veces hay congestionamientos de
tránsito etcétera entonces esta especie
de gps que es un pequeño bar o luminoso
luces verdes y rojas y nos indica para
qué lado doblar que voy a seguir según
la información que le llega a este
sistema a través de un satélite y según
si las luces verde se puede hablar por
ese lado y para dónde es roja conviene
evitar es un funcionamiento muy simple
que evita además tener el teléfono en la
mano que genera distracciones y
posibilidades de accidente que es lo que
le pasó al presidente de empresa
este sistema lamentablemente no tenemos
más tiempo les agradecemos una vez más
su presencia aquí escuchando seguirnos
cada semana en canal en las américas
café saludamos a todos los que no